yeah hello welcome to this video Dexter
Morgan your help he doesn't do anything
bad to me ok this is 4 out of 4 is my
score against this person so yet to drop
a point against him let's see ok so I'm
playing something risky so he again you
get chances I came a good old samish
line hear this 'if five people play that
every i may I should look this up there
this is this specific line the quick
nights is 685 I never thought it is that
great but people keep playing it against
me and down well this image is some just
on pure blitz opening for me I don't
play it in tournament chess maybe as an
as an occasional surprised but not
regularly it's a bit too risky but yeah
as I said people people keep playing
keep playing it against me and I don't
have a super clear recipe maybe I
shouldn't have canceled that early that
early on ok let's see that I'm ready for
f5 f5 now can be answered with f4
without cancelling what has this f 3g
for H for this pants porn porn store
option and now with having castle otters
is not not such a viable option looks a
little bit like down the huebner
variation now with both side simon
cowell short no like it black needs to
be a patient with them preparing a
possible f5 move you shouldn't do it
quickly but to take his time
okay night might come to f4 and a good
good night h5 here it's an interesting
IDM well its got to Queen h4 even now
it's not it's not not a big issue but
still so they could do it right f5s also
move and after let's do that not spend
more time okay I can prove pre-move this
one so likely that he takes the takes
the night but maybe he does nobody takes
them give them to you tonight back here
ok I'm going Queen to f3 this now is a
position almost from the hoop none
blacks best move now is probably I would
probably go key to H aid preparing
knight to e7 something like that keen to
our King a jade nice g8 and 97 what
black shouldn't do is take on f5 night
Bishop f5 f5 is a strategic mistake
after Queen takes f5 it's important to
take with the Queen and then why'd later
we'll play g3 and F for this kind of
thing and blacks huge disadvantage in
space is getting getting problematic
black should always try to challenge
this night in a way that there's no pawn
and no peace recapture possible so
something like night is 79 takes f5 this
is better even though here 97 ok he's
making this move move which I say that
said is a strategic mistake it doesn't
mean that he needs to lose now and
quickly but it is not the best way to
play I think a black should avoid this
kind of this kind of situation
oh really let's see i'm not quite sure
i'd like to play g3 and f3 but my queen
um Queen wants to go back I guess before
let's I can also click this and not
quite sure about the move on here h6 is
not quite clear to me Bishop g5 wasn't a
threat ok so now Queen a5 is not
possible anymore this is good news in
general I'm wondering about g3 maybe g3
Quincy aid is a move that I'm not quite
sure about maybe I have to shove age 6
even as a reply
completely unsure but this is also
something useful Queen 84 maybe this is
the move that I had on my agenda anyway
or at least I thought it might be useful
also stepping out of possible night F
for ideas the right moment to take my
membership there are funny ideas
sometimes like night air for Bishop
takes at 46 and the queen is short of
squares so I have to be a bit
circumspect there with my queen on f5
I'm kind of amazed how long how long he
takes here okay I think I'll go a form
make be five more difficult to play it's
not even trying to yeah trying to
increase the speed yeah this Bishop move
on Bishop age six instead of move now
interesting huh Bishop age six Queen
f-5e takes f5 yeah should be should be
quite good should win a partner and get
wins upon
Queen a five-year 5 i'm attacking the
knight on g6 so i should end up with an
extra pawn if you move the night away
i'm going to retreat my bishop and keep
the porn the only thing i don't like so
much is that well ma'am not really i
thought that his night might be better
than my bishop but that's not really
true i always have a crook f4 as an idea
interesting hmm i should be a little bit
alert him okay for
hmm through guy for but I have to ship
t3r that's not it's not a big problem
okay so f 393 I guess no good rugby to
maybe rugby to you for push it back to
be one III f3 should be okay don't see a
big problem this is I didn't see a
problem because I you can know what the
fact that c4 is attacked twice twice hmm
twice is not good
time morning taking what the night
looked a little bit more little bit more
dangerous okay I forward blunder that
porn sorry for the coffee maker cells
should really learn to switch that thing
off not wait until the auto power office
kicking in okay um like this I cannot
take you five that's a bit on switch
Bishop c4 okay King f2 is stepping into
a check maybe this one at bishop g6 now
check all rights not even that clear
check no it is Kim check check check
Royce really sped up here check black
for fits on time okay okay weird arrow I
think probably because I have that
database open I had a look at a couple
of games that I played online recently
okay so I won that game um pretty much
mostly due to my better knowledge of the
opening
it was all the structures that say it
really helped me about that I have this
experience from writing the book this is
a position that could easily have been
come from the hookah variation and it's
it's it's not a good idea to take in the
game gets very one-sided what black
usually wants to do is he wants to
challenge this night but with the night
yeah like 93 7 for example or something
like King here night back 97 there's
this kind of idea and try to take here
with his night ideally with this this
nightie and so if we just look at the
general idea let's say let's say this
move yeah okay my white might have night
h6e M not sure that it helps that much
but just a general idea what black would
like to do is something like take here
and then if the timing is right even
push efore now that's an additional idea
um yeah it's quite a quite a decent
position for black quite often against
h6 played already in this kind of
situation and then you go night h7 and
97 to try to change the night it's not a
good idea to take and like this this
position is very one-sided what white
wants to do is he wants to get the Queen
back off sometimes you can even keep it
on f5 and then push very slowly like g3
air form and like yep expand expand the
whole board and with the bishops as a
supporting forces will be very strong
blacks nights don't have any outpost
setter that make and there are any
relevant and yeah we got there I just
took a moment here and I would have
played g3 and so on but now he went
Queen d7 after which I'll just had
Bishop h6 whatever I think I didn't play
it well here I probably could have
played here should improve somehow maybe
yeah the engine gives this move as much
stronger this this and this and now i
have g3
okay I didn't calculate that for this
now lets me a piece who gave three
Bishop c4 here here and why there's a
piece up for not much now that that
would put up in better I absolutely did
not recognize that this is hanging twice
now and things get ya get to get messy
now I was more expecting him to take
with the night I wanted to go Bishop a
chore be should be three hours in quite
sure but it seems that white is better
this is and now I can take your next ok
so he played it right and you shall
leave it something went went wrong a
little bit later here yeah the engine
approves up to here but this is probably
not that great wants to go here man
gives equality it's a very sharp
position with the eight points running
and so on so this this and only this is
losing young king evade yeah sometimes
it's so easy a king of a to move you can
so easily miss as king at seven looks so
normal but here this Bishop g6 check is
out of the picture and here black is
completely okay if I go here he has this
yeah drastic solution takes and takes
and blackest black is probably okay
engine claims the quality yeah so he
probably lost this game in the opening
when he spent too much time so that it
wasn't able to get to play decent move
in the end game he's moved in the end
game okay thanks for watching